♪RESENTED BY FAN
DUEL.
I'M GREG IVORY ALONGSIDE ERIN
DOLAN.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY LOTS, GIVING
AWAY HOODIES AND NBA JERSEYS.
THE FIRST ONE IS GOING OUT RIGHT
NOW.
ERIN, YOU WANT TO GET IN THES C
THROUGH.
KEEP IT UP.
KEEP DROPPING THEM IN.
AS YOU CAN SEE, WE PUT OUT
HOODIES AND JERSEYS ARE ON THE
WAY.
SOME PEOPLE ARE COMMENTING MAVS
AND STUFF.
I NEED A MEME.
SOMEBODY DROP A MEME SO I CAN
GIVE A HOODIE OUT.
>> ERIN NEEDS A MEME.
I'M GOING TO JUST GIVE AWAY THIS
JERSEY RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU'RE GOING FOR IT?
>> RYAN RAY.
RYAN RAY, ACTUALLY -- ACTUALLY,
I GOT J.D. 2523.
RYAN RAY, YOU WILL GET A HOODIE.
ERIN WILL STILL GIVE OUT HER
HOODIE.
JD 2325, MAVS PLUS 10 1/2 IS A
LOCK.
>> I MIGHT BE HAVING TO GIVE
AWAY FROM A COMMENT.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> I GUESS THAT IS A LOT.
>> LOVE IT WITH THE JIMMY BUTLER
FACE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTING.
>> ERIN GAVE AWAY HER HOODIE.
JD 2523, HE'S GIVING OUT MORE
TAKES.
HE SAYS HEAT WIN.
LUKA TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
GOFF THE TAKES, JD.
WALKING AWAY WITH THE JERSEY.
WE'LL SEE IF HE GETS THAT
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT LATER IN
THE SHOW.
IT'S TNT TUESDAY, FANDUEL IS
RUNNING OUR FAVORITE BET.
THE 3x2 IN BOTH GAMES TONIGHT.
WILL THERE BE TWO THREE-POINTERS
IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES OF
THE GAME?
LAST WEEK THE 3x2 CASHED IN BOTH
TNT GAMES.
THE 76ers, THE KNICKS, NUGGETS,
JAZZ, TAKE A LOOK.
>> CHECK THIS OUT.
MY TEAM, IT WASN'T MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS, BUT THERE'S RJ BARRETT
THERE, DRAINING THAT THREE.
>> THE OTHER 30.
THAT'S THE OTHER 30.
STEPH CURRY IS 30.
BUT THAT'S THE OTHER 30 IN NEW
YORK.
>> LATER IN THE GAME, THERE YOU
GO.
MIKE CONLEY.
>> STEP BACK.
OKAY.
AND THEN THE JOKER GOT INTO IT.
THE JOKER GOT INTO IT.
WITH THE THREE.
>> MAKE IT LOOK SO EASY.
>> YES.
THEY MAKE IT LOOK SO EASY.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER
WHICH 3x2 WILL CASH TONIGHT?
MIAMI HEAT VERSUS THE DALLAS
MAVERICKS OR THE NEW ORLEANS
PELICANS TAKING ON THE SUNS.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
LET'S SEE THE RESULTS.
THERE THEY ARE.
MIAMI AND DALLAS IS IN THE LEAD
HERE.
WOW.
THIS IS SURPRISING.
>> WHY ARE YOU SURPRISED BY
THAT?
SO MANY SHOOTERS.
>> WELL, THERE'S SHOOTERS ON THE
OTHER SIDE, TOO.
I MEAN, WE KNOW WHAT PHOENIX CAN
DO.
THEY'RE SHOOTING ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
OKAY.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHICH 3x2 IS A LOCK TONIGHT.
GET CREATIVE.
I NEED GIFS.
I NEED EMOJIS AND I NEED MOST
IMPORTANTLY WINNERS ONLY.
ERIN, WHICH 3x2 DO YOU LIKE
BETTER?
>> SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE FIRST
GAME.
HEAT/MAVS, YOU HAVE DUNCAN RO
N
ROBI
ROBINSON.
THREE THREE-POINTERS MADE PER
GAME THIS SEASON.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BALL,
LUKA DONCIC, TIM HARD AWAWAY JR.
60% OF YOU ARE ROCKING WITH ME.
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY DROPPING
PICTURES OF LUKA.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE FIRST GAME.
YOU CAN BET ON BOTH OF THEM.
TAKE ADVANTAGE.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH MIAMI
VERSUS DALLAS.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS
HERE.
I GOT PRHY, HEAT AND DALLAS,
HE'S ROCKING WITH THE HEAT AND
DALLAS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
STAR NOVA WITH THE -- HE HAS THE
CARLTON GIF.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT MEANS.
BECAUSE HE'S IN HERE COMMENTING
AND CONTRIBUTING TO THE COMMENTS
IN THE SHOW, IT'S CARLTON
SHOOTING A BASKETBALL.
IT'S KIND OF RELATING TO WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
I HAVE LICCI 21 WHO SAYS THE
MIAMI HEAT AND THE MAVERICKS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT.
YOU CALLED IT, THE PEOPLE ARE
CALLING IT.
WE'RE RIDING AS A FAMILY.
THE MIAMI HEAT VERSUS DALLAS
3x2.
SO WE NEED THOSE VIBES.
I NEED EVERYBODY, GET SUNSETS IN
THE COMMENTS.
PUT IT IN THE COMMENTS AND SEND
US VIBES.
WE'RE RIDING THIS 3x2.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SEGMENT.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP HOW MANY
POINTS WILL LUKA DONCIC SCORE
TONIGHT AGAINST THE HEAT?
GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME HOW MANY POINTS LUKA IS
PUTTING UP AT THE END OF THE
GAME.
WE'LL DM ONE PERSON WHO GETS
CLOSEST AND HOOK YOU UP WITH THE
JERSEY.
ERIN, LUKA IS SITTING AT 25 1/2
POINTS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT
NUMBER?
>> SO, LUKA HAS ONLY HIT OVER 25
POINTS IN JUST TWO GAMES THIS
SEASON.
I'M ROCKING AND IT'S NOT FUN,
WITH THE UNDER.
THE HEAT ARE GREAT AT LIMITING
PLAYERS TO SCORING, JUST LIKE
THE DENVER NUGGETS.
LUKA WAS ONLY ABLE TO PUT UP 16
POINTS AGAINST THE NUGGETS LAST
FRIDAY.
GOING AGAINST THE TEAM LIKE THE
HEAT, THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SLOW HIM DOWN.
MIAMI HEAT ARE GOOD ON OFFENSE
BUT ESPECIALLY ON DEFENSE.
NEVER FUN TO ROCK WITH THE
UNDER, I WILL DO THAT FOR HIS
PLAYER POINTS PROP TONIGHT.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH THE
UNDER.
ERIN IS ROCKING WITH THE UNDER.
I'LL GIVE AWAY MY PICK.
I'M GOING WITH THE OVER.
I WILL TOUCH IT A LITTLE BIT
HERE.
I LIKE LUKA IN THIS MATCH-UP.
ACTUALLY I'LL SAY THAT I'LL ROCK
WITH THE OVER.
I WILL TOUCH IT LATER IN THE
SHOW.
I'M GIVING OUT HOODIES.
I GOT HGA BALLER SAYING LUKA'S
DROPPING 27 TONIGHT.
DROPPING 27 POINTS TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU HGA BALLER.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
JT FOR MVP 0 SAYS 25.
HE SAYS 25.
THAT MEANS HE'S GOING --
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING HAMMER
THE E ROCKING WITH ME.
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING HAMMER
THE OVER.
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING 38.
>> SOME PEOPLE ROCK WITH US, AND
SOME PEOPLE -- THEY DON'T ROCK
WITH US.
WE GOT RUWALDO WHO SAYS 27
POINTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
REMEMBER, AFTER THE GAME WE'LL
HIT ONE YOU GUYS UP.
WHOEVER IS THE CLOSEST AND WE'LL
HOOK YOU UP WITH THE JERSEY.
I HAVE ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY RIGHT NOW.
LET'S GET TO THE NEXT SEGMENT.
WE TALKED LUKA'S POINTS TOTAL.
FANDUEL IS HOOKING IT UP WITH
THE LUKA TRIPLE-DOUBLE BOOST
TONIGHT.
ERIN, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT'S UP.
>> SO, FANDUEL IS CURRENTLY
BOOSTING LUKA'S TRIPLE-DOUBLE
ODDS FROM PLUS 46 P
0 TO PLUS 6.
I KNOW HE HAS NOT HIT A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE THIS SEASON, A LOT
OF PEOPLE THINK THIS COULD BE
HIT.
IF YOU'RE FEELING RISKY, YOU
SHOULD GO FOR IT.
I WOULDN'T SAY PUT YOUR ENTIRE
BANK ROLL, MAYBE $5 ON IT,
CONSIDERING SOME OF HIS PARTNERS
IN CRIMES LIKE KRISTAPS
PORZINGIS BEING OUT THE LAST FEW
GAMES TO NURSE HIS BACK, I WOULD
SAY LUKA HAD TO PICK UP SOME OF
THE SLACK.
IF YOU WANT TO BET THE
TRIPLE-DOUBLE, I WOULD SPRINKLE
A BIT OF MONEY ON THAT.
>> I ACTUALLY LIKE THIS A LOT,
ERIN.
IF WE'RE ODDS BOOSTING IT, I
WILL BE SPRINKLING ON THIS
MYSELF.
WHEN LUKA GOES, THE MAVERICK
GOES.
WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO SH,
IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME KNOW
IF YOU GUYS THINK LUKA IS GOING
TO GET THIS TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
I'M ACTUALLY IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
REAL CUBAN SAYS NO TRIPLE-DOUBLE
HAPPENING AGAINST THIS EAT
DEFENSE.
NO TRIPLE-DOUBLES.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU REAL CUBAN.
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE ROCKING WITH
ME.
DID YOU SEE THE RECENT MEME?
LOVE THAT.
>> I DO SEE IT.
MARK 243 SAYS NO, HE WILL NOT
GET THE TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT.
DON'T LOSE YOUR MONEY.
I DON'T LIKE THE BAD VIBES,
BECAUSE I DO THINK LUKA IS
GETTING IT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO THE GOOD VIBES.
>> SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY WHO
COMMENTED.
YOU GUYS HAVE A FAIR RIGHT TO
YOUR OPINION.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
IF LUKA GOES OFF TONIGHT, HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT AGAINST
ONE OF THE TOP TEAMS IN THE NBA
RIGHT NOW, THE MIAMI HEAT ARE
ONE OF THE FOUR TEAMS WITH ONLY
ONE LOSS ON THE RECORD BOOKS.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY ON A FOUR-GAME
WINNING STREAK.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS IF YOU
THINK THEY'LL KEEP THE STREAK
ALIVE AGAINST THE MAVERICKS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
IF YOU THINK THE HEAT WILL BEAT
THE MAVERICKS TONIGHT.
ERIN, CAN THE HEAT BEAT THE
MAVERICKS TONIGHT?
AND WILL THEY COVER THE SPREAD?
>> SO LET'S GO THROUGH THIS.
THE MAVS ARE 3-0 AT HOME.
4-2 ON THE SEASON.
THEIR ONLY LOSS WAS TO THE
PACERS.
MIAMI IS 5-1 AGAINST THE SPREAD,
WHILE THE MAVTS HAVE WON EF
SINGLE GAME AT HOME THIS SEASON,
IT WAS AGAINST THE KINGS,
ROCKETS AND SPURS.
NONE OF THESE TEAMS CAN BE
EQUATED TO THE MIAMI HEAT.
I'M LAYING THE POINTS WITH THE
HEAT.
THE LINE OPEN AT MINUS 2, BET UP
TO MINUS 3.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MONEY LINE,
IT'S MINUS 152.
I THINK THE HEAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL.
I WILL SAY POTENTIAL, TO BLOW
THEM OUT OF THE WATER JUST
CONSIDERING HOW WELL THEY'VE
BEEN PLAYING ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE BALL.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE HEAT IN
THIS ONE.
>> I'M ROCKING WITH THE HEAT AS
WELL.
YOU MENTIONED THEY'RE 5-1, 2-1
AGAINST THE SPREAD ON THE ROAD.
I LIKE MY CHANCES THERE.
WE SEE SOME MOVEMENT IN THIS
LINE.
WE SEE SOME MOVEMENT.
I THINK THERE'S MOVEMENT FOR A
REASON.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE HEAT AS
WELL.
ERIN, LET'S TALK FUTURES.
THE HEAT ARE CURRENTLY PLUS 1200
TO WIN THE NBA FINALS.
IS THAT A GOOD VALUE FOR THEM?
GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN EARLY
ON.
>> SO, A COUPLE WEEKS BACK,
BEFORE THE START OF THE NBA
SEASON, WE WERE DOING ONE OF
THESE SHOWS.
I SAID I LIKED THEM AT 16-1.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE PIECES ON
OFFENSE AND DEFENSE.
THE PLAYERS HAVE TO STAY
HEALTHY.
I FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE A STACKED
ROSTER ON PAPER.
I THINK THIS LINE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE DOWN.
IT'S THE MIAMI HEAT, THEY
CONTINUE TO PLAY THE WAY THEY
ARE PLAYING, SO IF YOU LIKE THIS
LINE NOW, I WOULD GRAB IT BEFORE
IT MOVES DOWN.
>> ERIN SAYS SHE WILL GRAB IT,
BUT I'LL BE HONEST, I DON'T
THINK YOU GUYS SHOULD TOUCH THIS
MIAMI HEAT FUTURE.
THERE'S OTHER TEAMS THAT I SEE
THAT CAN WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
ALA THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
THAT'S MY TAKE.
ERIN, YOU WANT TO PICK A
COMMENTER TO WIN THE HOODIE ON
THIS ONE?
>> YES.
LET'S DO IT.
HOW ABOUT --
>> AFTER YOU.
>> YOU GET IN THERE AND I'LL GET
IN THERE.
>> HEAT WINNING TONIGHT.
LOVE IT.
WITH THE GIF.
THE GIF STANDS OUT TO ME.
>> ERIN LOVES THE GIFS.
>> SANDY GOAT.
SANDY GOAT SAYS THEY ARE LOOKING
VERY GOOD.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, SANDY GOAT.
I'LL GIVE OUT ONE MORE.
WHY NOT.
I GOT THE COMMENTS MOVING TODAY.
PAPA K 223 SAYS HE'S NOT TAKING
IT, THE HEAT IS NOT IT.
OH.
WE ARE MOVING ON.
YOU KNOW WE LOVE THE 3x2 AROUND
HERE.
BUT OUR OTHER FAVORITE QUICK
HITTERS ARE ERASE THE POINT
BETS.
I LOVE THE RACE TO TEN.
BUT TONIGHT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
RACE TO EIGHT.
I NEED YOU ALL TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH TEAM
IS GOING TO SCORE EIGHT POINTS
FOR TONIGHT.
WILL IT BE THE PELICANS OR THE
SUNS?
ERIN, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
THE PELICANS ARE OFF TO A ROUGH
START THIS SEASON.
CAN THEY GET EIGHT ON THE BOARD
FIRST?
>> ROUGH, IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
THEY ARE 1-6.
NO, I DON'T THINK THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO GET TO EIGHT POINTS
BEFORE THE DEFENDING WESTERN
CONFERENCE CHAMPIONS.
THE VALUE IS NOT THERE ON THE
SUNS TO SCORE THE FIRST EIGHT
POINTS AT MINUS 180.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BET INTO
THIS, I WOULD PUT $5 ON THE
PELICANS TO SCORE THE FIRST
EIGHT JUST GIVEN IT'S AT BETTER
VALUE.
IT COULD HAPPEN.
IT'S OFF THE BAT.
MAYBE SOMETHING HAPPENS AND THE
SUNS DON'T COME OUT ABLAZING,
BUT BE CAUTIOUS IN THIS MARKET.
>> YES, I AGREE WITH YOU.
IF YOU'RE SPRINKLING LIGHT
MONEY, 5 BUCKS, 10 BUCKS ON IT,
SPRINKLE IT ON THE PELICANS,
IT'S THE RACE TO EIGHT BET.
I DON'T LIKE THE MINUS 180 FOR
THE SUNS.
I WILL FOLLOW YOU HERE.
LET ME GET IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE -- OH,
MICHAEL SAYS THE SUNS AND HE
GAVE US A SUNSET.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, MICHAEL.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE A RUWALDO.
HE HAS A SUNSET.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
LICI 21 SAYS THE SUNS ARE
STARTING TO HEAT UP.
LOCK IT IN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
ERIN, I THINK I ALSO GAVE AWAY A
JERSEY HERE, RIGHT?
>> GIVING AWAY A JERSEY, GO FOR
IT.
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
AND I'M FEELING MOTIVATED.
I SEE MOTIVATED COMMENT DEVON
BOOKER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WINNING
THE HOODIE, NOT THE JERSEY
BECAUSE I SEE -- I SEE JULIO
HERNANDEZ.
JULIO HERNANDEZ SAYS THE SUNS
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE BETTER
TEAM, TB3 AND BOOK WILL GO OFF
AND GET OFF -- NO, THEY WILL GET
OFF TO A HOT START.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, JULIO.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
LaMELO, ERIN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT LaMELO.
LaMELO HAS BEEN GOING OFF
LATELY.
CHECK OUT THIS LaMELO SAME GAME
PARL
PARLAY.
MY GUY --
>> VERY IMPRESSIVE.
>> THERE IT IS.
LOOK.
CHECK THIS ONE OUT.
LaMELO GOT THE --
>> GOT TO HAVE A GREAT GAME.
>> YES.
YES.
HE GOT THE POINTS.
HE GOT THE ASSISTS, HE GOT THE
BOARDS AND THE THREES.
OUR GUY BET $100, HE WON $2,500.
SO LET'S LOOK AT SOME MARKETS
THAT LaMELO CAN IMPACT.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING YOU LIKE
HERE?
>> SO THE FIRST THING THAT JUMPS
OUT TO ME IS CHARLOTTE TO MAKE
THE PLAYOFFS PLUS 128.
I THINK THAT'S GOOD VALUE.
I DON'T SEE THEM WINNING THEIR
DIVISION, THE HEAT ARE IN THAT
DIVISION.
I DON'T SEE THEM WINNING THE
CONFERENCE.
I DON'T SEE THEM WINNING IT ALL
AS WELL.
I DON'T SEE LaMELO WINNING MVP.
THERE'S OTHER PLAYERS THAT ARE
BETTER IN THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
SO, IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT THIS
MARKET, THE SHORTEST LINE IS THE
PLUS 128 FOR THEM TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS.
I THINK OUT OF ALL THE OPTIONS
ON THE BOARD, THAT'S THE ONE I
WOULD GO WITH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ERIN SHOUT OUT TO YOUR PICK.
I'M GOING TO FOLLOW YOU WITH
THAT PICK.
I DO NOT SEE LaMELO WINNING MVP.
I DON'T THINK THEY'LL WIN THE
DIVISION.
DON'T THINK THEY'LL WIN THE
CONFERENCE AND DON'T THINK
THEY'LL WIN THE FINALS.
THE ONLY ONE THAT MAKES SENSE IS
THE PLUS 128 BET FOR THE
CHARLOTTE HORNETS TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS.
I DO SEE THEM HAVING THE
POTENTIAL TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS
THIS SEASON.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN OFF TO A HOT
START.
RHETT
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
G QUINN 24 SAYS I THINK
CHARLOTTE IS MAKING THE
PLAYOFFS, DEFINITELY A LOCK.
YOU WIN A HOODIE.
GOOD VIBES.
I GOT RUWALDO, SHOUTING OUT
LaMELO.
YOU ALREADY HAVE A HOODIE,
APPRECIATE YOU COMMENTING AGAIN.
KXP SAYS ABSOLUTELY NOT.
PLAYOFFS, YES, BUT NOT A TITLE.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED, YOU
GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, LET'S GET TO THE LAST
SEGMENT.
THIS WEEK AND FOR THE REST OF
THE SEASON I'M BUILDING MY
SAME-GAME PARLAY, NOW YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO RIDE WITH ME.
I NEED ALL OF YOU TO GET INTO
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF MY PARLAY?
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS?
WHICH LEGS ARE RUINING THE
PARLAY?
I NEED YOU TO GRADE MY PARLAY
FROM AN "A" TO AN "F."
THERE'S NO "F"s HERE.
GIVE ME "A"s.
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
I'M GIVING OUT A JERSEY TO MY
FAVORITE TAKE.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YES.
LET'S DO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT.
>> KYLE LOWRY.
I HAVE TO THINK WHERE I WANTED
TO START WITH IT.
LET'S START OFF WITH KYLE.
WE HAVE KYLE LOWRY 15 PLUS
POINTS LOCK IT IN.
SHOW ME SOME LOVE.
DO YOU LIKE -- DO YOU LIKE THIS?
HE'S AVERAGING EIGHT POINTS PER
GAME.
HE WILL HAVE TO GO OFF TONIGHT.
AGAIN, THE HEAT LOOK GOOD.
THERE'S ALWAYS A POTENTIAL FOR
HIM TO DO THAT.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
WE GOT TIM HARDAWAY, 15 PLUS
POINTS.
COME ON.
HE'S --
>> I DO LIKE THIS.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT LUKA, I
THINK LUKA WILL HAVE A GREAT
GAME.
FOLLOW ME HERE.
WE HAVE LUKA 25 PLUS POINTS, WE
GOT LUKA SIX PLUS REBOUNDS, AND
WE GOT LUKA EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS.
I THINK HE'LL HAVE A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER IN
THE SHOW.
I'M GOING TO SPRINKLE THAT ON TO
MY SAME-GAME PARLAY.
DO YOU LIKE THAT?
>> SO I KNOW THAT I SAID THE
UNDER FOR LUKA IS POINTS PROPS.
HOPEFULLY IF HE GOES OVER THIS
AND HITS ALL OF THESE, THE ODDS
CASH, THE SAME GAME PARLAY
CASHES.
GOOD SAME GAME PARLAY.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
I'M FEELING THE VIBES.
I NEED SUNSETS IN THE COMMENTS.
LET'S PUT THE ODDS UP.
THERE ARE THE ODDS.
YOU GUYS SEE IT.
836.
>> 836.
>> GET YOU SOME MONEY.
GET Y'ALL SOME MONEY.
ERIN, BEFORE I GET INTO THE
COMMENTS, WHAT ARE YOU GRADING
MY PARLAY?
>> I WILL GRADE YOUR PARLAY A
"B," ONLY BECAUSE I WAS GOING
UNDER FOR LUKA.
IF HE GOES OFF, THE SAME-GAME
PARLAY WILL HAVE A BETTER CHANCE
TO CASH.
I'M BANKING ON KYLE LOWRY TO
HAVE A GREAT GAME.
NEED HIM TO STEP UP.
>> OKAY.
>> B IS GOOD.
B IS GOOD.
>> B IS SOLID.
I GOT -- HOLD ON.
"A" PLUS FROM LAROSS GARZA.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
HGA BALLER IS WITH YOU.
GIVING ME A "B."
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, HGA BALLER.
DREW 84, ALSO GIVE ME AN A PLUS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I'M FEELING THE LOVE.
ERIN, I THINK IT'S TIME TO GET
ON UP OUT OF HERE.
THANK YOU FOR TAPPING INTO THE
GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE MIAMI VERSUS 3x2 IS A LOCK.
LUKA DONCIC IS GOING OFF.
THE HEAT FUTURES ARE LOOKING
GOOD EARLY.
AND GET ON FAN DUEL TO TELL MY
SAME-GAME PARLAY.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK GIVING
OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE JERSEYS,
MORE LOCKS.
IF YOU WON A HOODIE TODAY, WE
WILL DM YOU.
GET ON FAN DUEL, RIDE WITH US ON
SOCIAL, FOLLOW US ON SOCIAL.
FOLLOW ME, FOLLOWER  ERIN.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN, I'M GREG
IVORY.
WE'RE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
♪